hi my name is Steven Wright and I feel
anxious about being Conan O'Brien's
friend
it's the most honest way anyone has
opened this ironically it's not an
honest but I thought it would sound
I thought it would sound weird you have
one of the most iconic voices in comedy
and I'm not even talking about your
perspective which is Iconic but just
when you talking
um is such a delight to me every time
I've had the chance to interview you
I think my heart
beats maybe 200 beats a minute and I
think years beats during leap years
once and I've always loved the contrast
when I get to talk to Steven Wright
I'm
you know a Tasmanian devil and you are
um a moon rock that's seen it all it's
really beautiful the Moon Rock Casino
yeah yeah you have
well you know uh I'm lucky I sound like
this because obviously I'm not doing
this this is how I sound and it's
contributed to my whole career by
complete accident yeah I mean this is
just action but I'm not even though I
sound like this and I appear to be so
laid back I'm not as laid back as you
might think I am I'm not like you I'm
not like like yeah like like you know
like like on you know but but my mind
because
um that was the end of that sentences I
said no no no no
on one of my first jobs a writer named
Steve Barker who was from the Deep South
he looked at me one day and he used to
drink like whiskey out of his desk and
he just took a long sip of whiskey and
he went one day O'Brien you're gonna
blow and you're gonna leave a nasty
stain
because I was like 22 but bouncing off
the walls but anyway you said you're not
as laid back as one might think you are
my mind is going faster than than my
being to the outside world like I can I
exercise every day I'm an exercise bike
or a real bike I can get off the bike
get a phone call and hello oh did you
just wake up
right you know and you don't just work
40 minutes on the bike right so I can't
imagine like
I can tell you are
what you know you're tired if we were
made if we me and you were made out of
bamboo yeah I think about this all the
time okay let's continue that if you and
I were made of bamboo Bamboo poles like
20 each person had was 20 to make a
person yeah and they they have to wrap
them around to hold them together yeah
yours are wrapped
yours rattle a bit when you shake them
yes and mine feels like one solid yes
I'm basically there's some it's wrapped
so tightly on like a steel pole yes yeah
you use your version to drill for oil
yes
I've always thought I've always seen you
like Can I Tell You Stephen if I've
heard this I have to say if I've heard
this once I've heard it a thousand times
I have so many people in my life and so
like do you have a second when I'm in
the street
if you and I were bamboo you're wrapped
so tightly that usually do drove for oil
and I go I know I know and Stephen I
finished their sentence I go I know and
you drove for oil
all the time
oh my gosh
um I'm going to embarrass you really
quickly and then we can move on because
you're not gonna like this but
uh I am hard-pressed to think of anybody
who tickled my mind more when I was very
young and just interested in I mean
you know early 1980s
um 18 19.
and uh you explode on the scene
and
I it was such a revelation to me that
somebody could be so funny and so smart
in such an original way it was very
inspiring to me and to
I mean tens of thousands of people not
just from my generation but generations
going on
and I don't know if you're aware I know
you're a very humble guy but I don't
know if you're aware how much you
changed things
I hear about that I've influenced people
I've seen younger people uh that I can
tell influenced by me but that's very
nice of you to say that very nice and I
feel very lucky because I didn't
like I'm this is how I think that's how
I write this is how I speak and it just
it just fell together you know there was
no plan right if I do it like this like
this then I'll be this different guy it
was like go to the open mic night and
think okay I'm gonna go back and sweet
watch the open mic I'm gonna go back in
two weeks I wrote stuff I never written
anything so I wrote it during the two
weeks and I came back and then I was
saying it like I mean a lot my half of
it didn't work but
the distinctness is completely it's
explained by accident it's like a
fingerprint like your brain has a thing
everyone's brain is a fingerprint
and I'm so lucky that the thoughts and
the way I speak went together and I'm
also lucky that that it clicked with the
audience because I wouldn't have another
way to do it right right but thank you
thank you very much for the compliment
well another thing is when you're doing
it you're not thinking of a young kid
watching it you're just trying to make
the audience laugh you're trying to do a
good TV appearance you know I'm thinking
of 11 you know 14 year old people you're
not thinking no of course not I mean if
you are there'd be something wrong with
you
if every time you performed you were
thinking of a 14 year old boy
Steven that would be a real problem
are there any boys out there watching
hey take it easy Steven any little boy
is watching
um I'm gonna be arrested tonight I
didn't even say it I didn't even say it
no you kind of did say it and that hat
you're wearing is real Stevie
um
here's the thing I want to zoom in on
what I want to zoom in on that's
important to me is that yes your brain
is different and you have this way of
seeing things and you come along at this
certain time
the hard part is when you get up
and you're in the clubs there is a very
powerful powerful powerful force that
makes people want to conform because
there's a way to be that's a little
safer if you're in front of an audience
and
you clearly whether you want to
acknowledge it or not are brave because
you got up this is the way you were
going to do it
and I'm sure there were audiences that
didn't know what the hell is going on
initially
but you kept going you see what I'm
saying yeah that's the part that's not a
complete accident because you didn't say
you know it works it works when you get
up and go hey little Boston and then
you'll have a joke you know and then I
do some stuff for local local humor and
I kind of joke about the socks and I get
them on my side and then I'll try and go
into this stuff you knew that now that's
not that we're not doing that well I
didn't think of it to not do it I didn't
even think well I'm not going to do that
it just came out like it like it
happened
just so it but I made up rules I had
these four rules that I wouldn't do
that was on purpose to not
just say like a little separated can you
tell us the rules no
do you want to tell you my roles
I have 10 of them yeah Thou shalt not
kill
Thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's wife
um and maybe you should think about my
time yeah our rules are much more known
than mine
I love if your rules are just about
comedy but you're a sociopath about
everything else it's hilarious what the
you doing I was gonna say when you
said though she'll not kill I don't have
that
you come in your hands are all dirty
there's this there's a shovel in the
back of your car
very strict rules about non-topical
comedy very strict hey what happened to
that lady don't ask
oh my God